well if you're thinking about running
for Parliament it's too late nominations
for candidates in the general election
have closed and the list is expected to
produce more female and ethnic minority
MPs than ever before joining me now is
Katie go shoe is a chief executive of
the electoral reform society and we've
got also some analysis from on
prospective MPs in the 632
constituencies which has produced a
likely makeup of the Parliament
obviously depending on who wins this is
what the insight consulting group found
and we can look first of all at women
MPs up from 148 to 205 of course that's
still less than the third but a pretty
significant jump it is a significant
sign of progress and it's a bit more
optimistic than what we're predicting
we're saying around 192 and peace but as
you've said that still wouldn't even
take us to a third which I think just
shows how on reflective our Parliament
still is a society at large and what why
has their business increased we now are
the parties trying in the sense of
making fo rather than exasperated but
the parties are trying i think they are
making real efforts and but of course
what really matters is putting women in
safe seats i think the parties are doing
better at putting them in winnable seat
some of the marginals we have an
electoral system that obviously
encourages a culture of lots of safe
seats where you have incumbents mainly
men who've been there for many decades
and I think until we sort of see a
change to that we're not really going to
have the chance for parties to do the
right thing if you like and have a real
jumping women do we know if you have a
woman can that are you more likely or
less likely to be elected we don't know
but what we do know which is encouraging
is that women has certainly seen every
bit as favorably as men and so I guess
that's a good sign ok let's look at
black and minority ethnic mp's again
anticipating a considerable increase
there yes what I'm interested about that
figure though is that again if
Parliament was to reflect the number of
non-white people in our population guess
how many MPs there would be from long
white backgrounds it would be 84 so a
progress is really being made but we're
not seeing a parliament that really
reflects modern Britain I mean I think
it was only nineteen eighty-three when
black and minority ethnic mps were
elected for the
first time since the Victorian age so
it's been a fairly rapid move again can
we say one party is doing better than
any of the others or and it's really
difficult to say because the nominations
have only just closed we've not been
able to kind of really crow closely sort
of pour over all those and figures yet
but I think again it's an area where the
parties are really realizing that they
have got to do more and I think the
reason is this that when people are
asked why they're so fed up with
politics and party politics one of the
strongest reasons they give is that
Parliament doesn't look and feel like
them i mean i should say these are just
provisional figures aid because we don't
know who's that you're going to win the
election and be because we haven't done
the full analysis as you say of the
final figures today but i think there's
one more just about the background of
MPs now this is interesting oxbridge
graduate mp's pierre people have been to
Oxford and Cambridge labour slightly
more than a quarter conservatives about
a 5th but more oxford graduates than for
example black and ethnic MP absolutely
and there's a there's a bigger issue
here as well which people comment on
which is first of all so many more
people who've done nothing but politics
and their life going into Parliament has
been a really increase of those over the
last 10 to 20 years but also again in
terms of social class social backgrounds
we don't have a parliament that has
people from every walk of life we're
very long way off flat and in some ways
we've gone backwards on that I think
that what we have certainly in terms of
people from from kind of had experience
of a manual job if you like can you guys
thank you very much indeed